hey guys right at the outset I have to
tell you Bear is okay he's doing well
come on little puppy go boy okay look at
his giant face clean your face you're on
camera he isn't going traveling
this isn't his neck pillow this is his
aunt I lick his incision pillow
basically he can't turn around all the
way with this cuz it's so big that if he
wants to lick himself he just can't he's
been wearing this for the last week he's
pretty comfy with it and used to it by
now but I'm gonna take it off for the
video because I can watch him right now
and make sure he doesn't lick anything
that he's not supposed to except me the
surgery that he had was you may have
guessed it
he was neutered snip snip for poor
little bear there's a few reasons why I
decided to get bear neutered but that
wasn't an easy decision I actually went
back and forth a few times
first of all bear has a snaggletooth I
don't know if anyone has seen it he has
the snaggletooth and I was kind of
worried if we would bother him long term
so I thought you know let's do two birds
one stone type situation get him
neutered and while he's under anesthesia
they can a clean his teeth and be get
the tooth out however when this little
guy went under anesthesia they did
x-rays and they found that he has an
extra canine to bear you have three
canines if you're wondering the canine
tooth is this bottom tooth right here
the big one and he literally has an
extra one that's growing outward when
the doctor did the x-rays it seemed like
that the roots were so interconnected
with all the other teeth that by taking
it out there may be damage done to the
other teeth she was worried about that
so she explained that since he's eating
well there's no pain there's no
discomfort they decided to keep the
tooth in so bear is still having his
three canines the pros to neutering the
dog really come from a it changes their
behavior for the better slightly for
male dominant dogs there's decreased
marking decreased humping decreased
reaction to females and heat bear didn't
have any of those really issues I mean
occasionally when he would see a female
dog he would get really excited he's not
aggressive in any way he's super
friendly then I started looking and
doing research on what would be the pros
I'm a health standpoint forbear I have
to say at the outset of this I'm not a
vet I am a medical doctor although some
people have gotten that confused in the
past Roxy the things that I found were
mainly from quality research and
speaking with some really experienced
dog trainers veterinarians things like
that so if you're thinking about
neutering your dog don't neuter your dog
simply because your dog is doing
something that you don't like and you
think that's gonna be a cure-all train
your dog I think for controlling the pet
population in general it's a good idea
but you shouldn't be using it as a
cure-all for some behavioral issue
unless it's specifically recommended to
you by veterinarian and or a trained
behavioral specialists for dogs now bear
never really had any issues he was
attacked one time and that's a crazy
video I'll link that down below but in
general he's a happy new he loves
playing with other dogs lately I haven't
been letting him play with dogs because
I'm trying to get him ready for his
certification to come with me to the
hospital and we want bears to be well
trained for that so I haven't been
letting him play with too many puppies
in the dog park mostly just Roxy when
she comes to visit or he goes to visit
her there's a lot more health benefits
for spaying a female dog than neutering
a male dog like there are decreases and
some cancers for male dogs like
testicular prostate issues but in
reality not too many health benefits
there are certain studies going around
saying that dogs who are neutered live
longer I take those studies with a grain
of salt because dogs that have been
neutered generally get better veterinary
care they have owners that are attentive
to them it's no surprise that they live
longer
at least there's evidence that they
don't live a shorter life because some
people have said that like oh my god
you're gonna take away the testosterone
that means the dogs are gonna live a
shorter life that's not true we have
evidence of that at least my main reason
why I wanted to neuter bear is if I
travel and I'm gone for a day or two and
I leave bear with my dad or a friend I
don't want the possibility of bear
becoming a baby daddy you are I don't
want to pay doggy child support when he
impregnates a little chihuahua so we got
bear fix primarily for that reason he's
doing great after the operation he's
like a happy new he's healing well did
you get hiccups on camera
Oh years it comes oh my god dad you have
to show the footage of him when he was a
little baby having hiccups on my lap he
has hiccups growing pups always have
hiccups that's not new
so that doesn't even concern me if you
have any questions about what it's like
to get your dog neutered or your
wondering whether you should drop a
comment down below not a vet but I can
share my own personal experiences and
things that I found online bear are you
excited to open up some mail
good boy wow he went in my face for that
good boy speak high-five whoa that was
close you almost hit me right in the
face oh this one's from family okay it's
something dense it's a burrito tortilla
blanket for adults and kids so you can
be all wrapped up for the upcoming
winter season Casey oh this is a big one
from revived rink where dr. Mike first
off you need to know that because of
your first morning routine video I've
started diligently floss every day well
done thank you so much for the content
you're producing for all of us I
honestly cannot fully Express how
incredibly helpful I find to have such
an immediate and entertaining resource
for varying healthcare topics well thank
you for that battle and let's see what
we got here first we got a stainless
steel mug Oh stay happy and healthy look
at that and ready BAM this is fire let's
see what the clever one is ooh in case I
need to go for a walk slash run dude
this is way too good even the font you
chose is better than Madeleine you're
good
okay we got a shirt ABCD efg hijk LMNOP
qrs tuv
we'll get this this is a p-wave that's a
cue wave or wave S wave T wave I'm gonna
wear this one day to work when I'm just
coming in to do notes and I'm telling
you my hospital is gonna go bonkers for
it this is hilarious well done
yeah Nika Nix from the Netherlands our
work inside careful well I feel like a
kid on Christmas but and christmas is
coming up bear inside least I'm not
cutting myself with that letter opener
like I did last time
hi dr. Mike hopefully the bear pup has
made it to your doorstep safely I hope
you liked the drawing I wanted to thank
you for your way of practicing medicine
patient understanding and looking at the
bigger picture is important for both the
patient and the doctor I thank you for
saying that
oh this is crazy this is you oh my god
no don't lick it
don't lick it don't like it this is just
its next level this is gonna be a main
attraction in my home this is ridiculous
Thank You Naomi bishop from Wyoming oh
the do symbol with dr. Mike on it I love
that oh it's a little canvas this is too
adorable
Monet Roxy and bear Naomi you crushed it
this is from Carol serenity Oh serenity
get it you really had to draw the her
pee
this is really good that's really sweet
hey Mike
I am Harris me Pegula and I'm a great
fan of your videos in your amazing
mentor I'm pre-med at UMD but I could
receive an autograph it would mean a lot
to me only if you get some time oh
that's awesome well do their doctor Mike
my name is Romanian I'm 32 from Germany
and I'm sending you a drawing of you and
bear I want to say thank you for the
great YouTube channel it's funny
informative and I really enjoy watching
it I'm not healthy because I have cancer
but I try and stay happy no matter what
drawing is my daily healthy drug that
helps to keep me happy and of course
watching you and bear on YouTube so
thank you and I hope you like my drawing
wow it's great last but not least it's a
bacteria no it's a mitochondria
powerhouse power house this is hilarious
I love giant microbes thank you for the
mitochondria check out a playlist of
bear and roxy videos right here I love
playing with these pups and I know
you're gonna enjoy it
[Music]